les affaires qui concernent dominique
strauss kahn ne se comptent plus mais
nic strauss kahn inc strauss kahn
dominique strauss kahn jeudi dernier
cache investigations consacré d'ailleurs
son enquête sur les agissements de l'ex
patron du fmi dominique strauss kahn n'a
plus de boulot mais s'il a un gros
réseau une émission qui a remis sur le
tapis une affaire remontant à 2014 une
soi-disante affaire d'escroquerie
organisé avec l'homme d'affaires thierry
lane pour se renflouer ils veulent créer
un fonds d'investissement international
un énorme coup alors qu'à cette époque
dsk et lui cherche des fonds et donc des
investisseurs pour sauver leur société l
essca de la faillite il aurait mis le
grappin sur un couple de retraités alain
et sylvie hubac le couple pensant mettre
leur argent en lieu sûr aurait perdu
toutes leurs économies un montant qui
s'élèverait à plus d'un million d'euros
aujourd'hui l'affairé n'est toujours pas
résolu alors que yoann hâte alors avocat
temps d'obtenir réparation alors dsk
at-il vraiment escroqué un couple de
retraités alain et sylvie robach et
leurs avocats sont avec nous sur le
plateau ce soir pour tenter d'éclaircir
cette affaire alors au natal avocats de
sylvia lagerback est avec nous on va
voir à la rubrique dans un instant en
facetime mais n'ont pas pu se déplacer
et s'il dit je sais pas si elle aura le
rejoins nous pas mon or en tout cas
alain c'est sûr merci néonatale d'être
avec nous alors c'est vrai que cette
histoire quand on a vu le reportage
jeudi soir on n'ya pas cru et on s'est
dit c'est incroyable c'est donc
l'histoire d'un couple de retraités qui
va faire confiance on va dire entre
guillemets aux mauvaises personnes qui
va se faire arnaquer tout seco de ses
économies pour ne plus rien avoir plus
d'un million d'euros disparaissent dans
la nature
c'est pas satisfaites à faire c'était
toutes leurs économies comment ils ont
pu mettre toutes leurs économies et
comment ça s'est passé comment ils ont
fait la connaissance de ces personnes
bonsoir merci au niveau du montant je me
permets juste de préciser que c'est le
jet d'un million cent quarante mille
euros c'est incroyable un minois en ce
qui
représente une somme et qui constitue
tout simplement en fait le fruit
de l'epargne qui a été mis de côté
jour après jour mois après mois année
après année avec donc à une épargne qui
leur permettait d'entrevoir sereinement
leur avenir et celui de leurs enfants et
donc ils ont été incités à placer des
fonds qui jusqu'àlors était dans une
banque française
ils ont été approchés initialement
partir il n qui est l'associé de
dominique strauss kahn d'accord puisque
tir hélène et dominique strauss kahn ont
décidé de monter une entité qu'ils ont
choisi de désigner comme l essca elle
comme la
jsk comme strauss kahn
donc
cette entité faisait coût allant alors
cette entité en fait elle a été
présentée aux époux comme une banque
l'accord est une banque d'affaires en
particulier
l'histoire nous apprendra que dominique
strauss kahn n'est jamais eu en fait
l'agrément bancaire pour pouvoir
discuter sur ce terminologie la de
banque qui est rassurante et qui en fait
un site à la confiance et qui permet à
l'épargnant aussi de savoir que ces
fonds ne sont pas soumis à un risque
exagéré alors c'est dans une soirée qui
vont rencontrer le bras droit de dsk
dont vous nous parlez en 2014 il va les
convaincre d'investir leurs économies
dans la société et l'esca ils vont
investir toutes leurs économies toutes
leurs économies effectivement
c'est une heure a promis quoi mais en
fait de pérenniser leur épargne et de
permettre en fait
à leur épargne de fructifier par
définition quand vous avez réussi à
mettre des fonds de côté vous avez une
inflation chaque année qui fait que en
fait 100 euros d'aujourd'hui
représentera 50 euros dans dix ans donc
en fait c'est un schéma classique
ils ont été approchés
c'est un fonds spéculatif comme il y en
a beaucoup alors c'est pas fonds
spéculatifs justement en fait il s'est
investi c'est contre les fluctuations du
marché tout à fait ce qui a été en fait
présenter aux époux c'était une banque
d'affaires et oui une banque d'affaires
avec les initiales de dominique strauss
kahn comme gage de garantie avec un
rapport de confiance tout à fait à 30
alors ils sont pas méfiés une seconde
ils vont investir en tout donc nous la
vie nous lever 1 million sont quarante
mille euros on va avoir tout de suite
alain urbact qui fait partie du couple
qui veut le mari voilà de ce couple à
alain et sylvie ou qui va nous raconter
de sabon soir alain merci d'être avec
nous
pour ça merci merci à vous merci aux
personnes
présentes aux animateurs et bien
d'autres ont dû avoue shihri malheureux
ils sont payés
sont là pour ça voilà si je peux vous
détendre un peu à la en tout cas merci
d'être là parce que votre histoire les
folles et elle nous a tous énormément
touché un million cent quarante mille
euros les économies de toute une vie
pour alain et sylvie et vous êtes
retrouvé au coeur d'une arnaque qu'est
ce qui s'est passé exactement comment
vous avez vu vous avez perdu un million
cent quarante mille euros qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
en fait avant avant de répondre à votre
question je vais faire un petit
historique si vous le permet avec
plaisir
et effectivement on est et on a été
approché par par monsieur laine qui est
le bras droit de dominique strauss kahn
on nous a apporté beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de noeux preuve de sérieux et
c'est aussi bien au travers des valeurs
des actions au travers du capital de
puisqu'il s'agissait de rentrer au
capital de
cette banque d'affaires
et lescar on a vérifié on a vérifié
avant d'investir bien entendu on a
vérifié
les dires de
retirer l'aide et tous avérés
effectivement comme étant des la vérité
donc on a effectivement
on est des gens relativement simple il
s'avère que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
une vie professionnelle très intéressant
et bien fait faux témoins
en fait j'ai travaillé très tôt dans
l'informatique puisqu'avant je suis
maintenant à la retraite et juste pour
pour apporter une petite image
je travaille dans une société qui
s'appelait digital equipment qui à
l'époque était le numéro deux mondial de
l'informatique d'accord et mon service
s'est occupé de l'arrivée des premiers
pc dans le monde d'accord
je vous laisse imaginer bien serait ce
que ça veut dire bien sûr dont vous avez
pu être une très belle somme de côté un
million cent quarante mille au toutes
vos économies et là on vous dit de
déplacés c'est ça c'est le bras droit de
dsk qui m'a alors déplacé dans ce avant
que c'est ça voilà tout à fait
l'objectif c'était de les placer dans le
capital de l'entreprise
avec on avait une garantie écrite bien
entendu qui consistait à dire que si on
voulait ressortir de ce capital ne
pouvait le faire mais au moins avec un
préavis d'une quinzaine de jours
d'accord sachant qu'on rentrait avec un
prix qui étaient inférieures bien
inférieur à celui du marché alors vous
avez essayé de sortir action vous avez
essayé de sortir avant votre argent
c'est ça ah bah on a mais on n'a même
pas réussi à rentrer enfin
avoir une journée puisque en fait le
jour où le virement bancaire a été fait
vers le comté lescar le lendemain matin
tout l'art tout l'argent a disparu
en est rendu compte tout de suite alors
on s'en est pas rendu compte tout de
suite parce que maintenant attendu les
mouvements bancaires comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer prennent un petit peu de
temps mais très très vite quand on a
commencé à avoir des appels télécharger
avoir des appels téléphoniques que ça
soit sur ou au niveau du conseil
d'administration d'ing escales etc
plus personne ne répondait on avait plus
d'interlocuteur il y avait plus personne
n'y avait plus rien voilà savez vous
avez eue dsk lui-même au téléphone avant
de mettre l'argent c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit oui tout à fait tout à fait c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné on mais dans
un des bureaux de tir il n y avait le
notaire de
l'esca qui était à côté de nous d'accord
aussi papier effectivement
les escales passer un petit coup de fil
pour nous féliciter on va dire
d'être entré dans
le capital de son entreprise et donc
c'est un million cent quarante mille
euros envolés
sont sans parti une petite anecdote qui
est très intéressante et qui dénote bien
le côté très particulier de monsieur
dominique strauss kahn
c'est qu'on devait faire le virement sur
une certaine banque et l'arrêt du
virement on nous a demandé de faire le
virement sur une autre banque dans un
autre pays en l'occurrence en suisse
d'accord donc sur un compte récemment
ouvert de que la société et lescar qui
avait ouvert deux jours plus tôt
on n'a pas
moi que ce soit par rapport à ça donc
sauf que oui après on a su pourquoi ça
avait été fait comme ça il faut savoir
le mans parce que dsk avait une amie à
qui il devait beaucoup d'argent et c'est
amy elle avait un compte dans cette
banque la et donc ça permettait de faire
un virement de compte à compte d'une
façon extrêmement rapide mais c'est
incroyable comment on peut ne pas
récupérer l'argent m c'est fou parce que
comment ça se passe là envolée c'est une
bonne question et je reviens sur ce qu'a
dit bernard des quelque chose de très
important à saisir si effectivement
était dans le cadre d'un fonds
spéculatif
vous pouvez entreprendre un mauvais
investissement et quand on investit avec
du risque et bien soumis au risque là
ici ce qu'ils auraient été proposés
c'est une entrée dans le capital c'est
ça de la société de dominique strauss
kahn avec un acte notarié quittez donc
alain s'est déplacé avec son épouse doit
tout à fait pour pouvoir signer cet acte
quand vous signez un acte notarié et que
vous regardez que la société est cotée
en bourse nation il s'est rendu compte
après que le cours boursier a été
trafiquée afin d'attirer des
investisseurs et de leur proposer à un
prix préférentiel
donc comme c était précisé jusqu'à
présent
la première fois que j'ai reçus donc
alain et sylvie au cabinet
je pense que vous en souvenez c'était en
fait silence pleurs quelques paroles
silence pleurs quelques paroles et on
partait de zéro à rien parce que au-delà
de tout ce qu'on a pu constituer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui qui sont des éléments de
preuve on partait en fait uniquement
avec un virement un site internet len
strauss-kahn où vous avez en fait
dominique strauss kahn en qualité de
président du conseil d'administration
qui a entouré d'une équipe assez
conséquente puisque dix personnes en
fait composé le conseil d'administration
et donc le président
donc dominique strauss kahn
ah si vous voulez étaient très
intelligents parce que aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'on est devant le suicide
c'est facile pour lui de dire que c'est
son associé qui était un escroc et que
lui en fait c'est même lui même fait
avoir alors qu'on s'est rendu compte
qu'en fait dominique strauss-kahn
lui-même disait aux investisseurs qu'il
a investi lui-même ses deniers
personnels mais quand on a regardé
d'intérieur il s'agissait pas d'un
investissement il s'agit simplement
d'une promesse d'investissement mais
lorsque vous créer toutes les conditions
pour créer de la confiance et qu'ensuite
la personne a mordu à l'hameçon bien
donc elles étaient emprisonnés la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est de
savoir pourquoi dominique strauss kahn
at il pris un risque pareil mais ça
c'est fou
il faut il faut absolument comprendre
que 2000 strauss kahn au moment où il
est entré et a créé sa banque entre
guillemets sa banque d'affaires ils
étaient persuadés qu'ils allaient
réussir il indiqué
qu'il serait au bout de cinq ans plus
grand que la banque lazard et donc en
fait les voeux de dominique strauss kahn
était partie peut-être d'une bonne
intention là où ça a été totalement
malhonnête et que ça confine à de
l'escroquerie
c'est lorsque vous savez que votre
entité morte et que vous appelez des
investisseurs pour amortir votre chute
et que vous utilisez par exemple le
fruit de leur investissement pour
rembourser déjà des personnes donc qui
elle
réclame leur investissement et leur dû
donc voilà un peu là alain d'avoir juste
aujourd'hui
vous avez quand vous faites pour vivre
c'est une question à laquelle il est
très difficile de répondre
j'étais obligé de prendre des empreintes
et c'est très compliqué
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aujourd'hui alain recour parce que je
sais que votre avocat fait énormément
qu'est ce qu'il est possible de faire
des recours pour que c'est quoi leur on
a envie d'enlever remué ciel et terre
pour que en fait tout simplement l'on
vous invite à une révolution alors mise
en examen
le conseil d'administration l'ensemble
des membres du conseil d'administration
soit mise en examen soit jugé mais soit
condamné à la hauteur du préjudice qu on
a subi c'est tout moi il ya c'est la
seule chose ça fait sept ans que ça dure
et en fait on n'a pas avancé d'un pouce
si j'ose le dire comme ça c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui
dominique strauss kahn ni vie très très
bien tout va très bien je me demande
d'ailleurs d'où vient ce et ses
premières conférences où il a amassé
tellement d'argent si quelque part ça
vient pas d'eux de l'argent de l'esca ça
c'est mon avis personnel qui n'engage
que moi mais d'un autre côté
moi d'un point de vue fiscal par exemple
j'ai été passer au laser mais qu'on
série fier
l'ensemble des sommes que j'ai investi
avait été bien déclarer au fisc en temps
et en heure que tous les revenus que
j'avais eue c'était des revenus déclarés
et c c'est à dire que moi je suis passé
au laser comme si c'était moi j'étais le
le coupable alors alors je minimum le
minimum c'est que le conseil
d'administration
passé au laser de la même façon
alors vous avez donc mis toutes vos
économies un million cent quarante mille
euros qui sont envolés aujourd'hui je
sais que votre femme a préféré de ne pas
parler ça parce qu'elle se sentait pas
la force de le faire
moralement je sais que c'est extrêmement
compliqué est-ce que vous avez encore
espoir
vous savez on vit
moi depuis depuis très très jeune cela
vient certainement de
de mes origines je j'ai toujours
travaillé pour mes enfants
et aujourd'hui malheureusement avec tous
les plans que j'avais mis en place et
tout ce que j'avais fait je ne peux pas
les aider et ça fait extrêmement
difficile pour moi
déjà vous est ce que vous arrivez à
vivre c'est ça le plus essentiel d'être
aussi bon
on va dire qu'on survit je vais pas me
plaindre il ya des gens qui sont dans la
rue je vais pas me plaindre mais fait
très compliqué
c'est un million cent quarante millions
ou est ce que on a une chance de l'est
de les revoir pour asi dit alain m
atteint alors c'est toute la question il
faut savoir que en droit français la
jurisprudence est constante sur ce point
pas de mise en examen pas de procès donc
aujourd'hui en fait ce qui semble une
lenteur de la justice
est à mon sens lié aussi à la
personnalité
de la personne incriminée si cette
affaire avait concerné une personne qui
n'avait pas autant d' influence je pense
que ça fait très longtemps qu'on aurait
eu au moins une mise en examen puisque
la mise en examen consiste finalement à
avoir donc une succession d'indicés
graves et concordants
on a un acte notarié on a un cours de
bourse qui en fait donc a été dévoyé on
a une appellation de banque qui a été
utilisée alors qu'aucun agrément 1 était
là et on se bat pour faire entendre
notre voix je vous remercie infiniment
de la sensibilité que vous avez exprimé
j'ai vu la séquence vendredi donc ou il
était question de moralité ou pas
effectivement je suis guillaume quand il
indique que on a le droit d' optimiser
fiscalement
donc son patrimoine c'est la question
voilà n'était pas là et surtout ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que depuis
l'escroquerie on a eu donc une ouverture
d'une instruction qui a précédé en fait
une enquête préliminaire et donc en fête
qui était qui a été permise par la
plainte que nous avions déposé est une
question qui se pose est c'est pourquoi
seul le couple en fête a été escroqué
alors qu'on a eu 160 investisseurs et
104 millions d'euros il ya disparu
totalement du 140 millions d'euros
contre 104 millions d'euros qui ont
disparu et pourquoi parce que en fait
tout simplement
pour pouvoir établir une plainte en
france encore faut-il que les personnes
incriminées soient françaises ou que les
victimes soient françaises et que les
fonds soient français est donc le cas de
figure est
donc bien respectée en l'espèce
l'entrée au capital de la banque
d'affaires ça a été finalement en fait
donc que les époux qui l'ont connu
puisque jusqu alors les personnes qui
investissent et n'entrez pas au capital
donc l'entrée au capital n'a concerné
que monsieur et madame merci alain
d'avoir écrit que moscou 0-1 derniers
mois nous dire ce que vous avez essayé
d'appeler dominique strauss kahn ou lu
par lui-même parce que même de parler
avec le coeur il ya rien et mine de rien
c'est vrai que c'est si incroyable alors
j'ai posé j'ai échangé avec l'un de mes
confrères qui intervient ce serait
intéressant de le recevoir également
pour avoir aussi peut-être bien sûr sa
version wii et donc il m'avait dit en
fait avec une formule qui appartenait à
jacques brel en me disant vous
connaissez mon client n'a n'a pas le sou
il n'a pas le moyen donc j'ai dit
arrêtez de me prendre pour un brel
je pense que en fait l'histoire est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça et que en
fait l'avocat de dominique strauss kahn
sur cette affaire c'est ça nous a dit ça
oui oui il faudrait que l'on reçoive
d'ayant avec avec plaisir à alain
merci d'avoir été là ce soir
nohant prix nous avons pris j'espère
simplement que voilà si vous pouvez
faire quelque chose
je demande qu'une seule chose c'est que
justice soit rendue